[Music]
Wow it certainly as a full house tonight
welcome to Wango Tango this is not your
first mango tango row do not know who
are you excited to see you tonight
well everyone but of course tailors if
Jonas Brothers Aly Brooke I know and I'm
introducing said tonight so that's
really super cool are your kids with you
here today my kids are here not doing
the carpet they're like laying low but
we're all here it's a family night to
watch your story and particularly about
the going back to work fuller house
watching you made me emotional what was
choking you up so much about that day
oh goodness I've been a big crybaby I've
the whole week like every day and it was
only our first week back but just we've
had such an amazing run on fuller house
and I work with my best friends every
day so knowing this is our last season
is quite bittersweet we're so happy that
we get to do a whole nother season but
knowing it's their last like we're
savoring every moment of it but it's
emotionally really hard because I love
what I do and I love the people I work
with
last time I talked to you you said you
weren't sure where the show was gonna go
in this season so now that you've read
the first what couple scripts let me
just tell you because we tape the first
episode last night and it was oh good
it's so emotional it's funny my friend
carry my baby before you called me your
friend I should have had your baby in
middle school we have a new baby on the
show this season because Kimmy had
carried Stephanie's baby and so there's
gonna be a lot of little you know little
baby and kid hijinks going on but I
think we're gonna give the fans a lot of
the emotional stuff that you that you
want to see in love about family because
we're wrapping the show up I know yeah
you know how it ends yet I do and I'm
not telling our fans gonna be happy with
how it ends I think so yeah I mean I'm
pretty sure there might be a few that
it's like Game of Thrones you can't
please everyone you're gonna try but I
think everyone is generally gonna be
very happy I know you can't say anything
but thinking about DJ's journey give me
like a little hint well you know I've
already said this in interviews it's
very safe to say there gonna be some
wedding bells okay Stephanie and Jimmy
are getting married this season even DJ
will be - I quit deej we've been waiting
25 years
hey we owe it to ourselves once and for
all to just see how we were as a couple
oh they're together and I think I think
all the fans will be happy because
you're gonna see a very long
relationship finally become what it's
always meant to be
yeah could we see a double wedding there
could be yeah I love how positive you
always keep it and I don't want to touch
on what I'm not supposed to touch on but
how will you guys address aunt Becky's
absence
I forgot how beautiful oh nothing
it hasn't been discussed I have
absolutely no answer for it and and
Netflix has not even spoken about it
so I have no answer thank you so much I
appreciate it yeah
you